Prime Minister confirmed Turkish
commitments to accept the rapid return
of all migrants coming from Turkey to
Greece that are not in need of
international protection the days of
irregular migration to Europe are over
we agreed to work on the basis of the
following principles the return of all
new regular migrants crossing from
turkey into the Greek islands the
speeding up of the disbursement of the
three billion euros and additional
funding for the refugee facility for
Syrians and finally to resettle Syrian
refugees on a one-for-one basis I was
assigned by leaders to take forward
these proposals and work out the details
together with the Turkish side before
the next European Council we also
discussed with Prime Minister Davutoglu
the situation of the media in Turkey we
all know how important is the freedom of
speech and expression one of the
fundamental human rights I am saying all
this because we cannot stay indifferent
to the concerns raised in this context
about what is now happening in Turkey we
made a bold decision to accepting all
irregular illegal migrants and we will
be accepting them based on the
assumption that for every syren
readmitted by turkey from greek islands
another serum will be resettled by
europe with this game-changing position
in fact our objective is to discourage
illegal migration to prevent human
smugglers to help people who want to
come to Europe through encouraging legal
migration in a discipline eyes and
regular manner
you